oh
i just can't hello everyone i'm abby
sharp welcome
back to abby's kitchen
today's video is sponsored by
squarespace and we are back to review
another celebrity
harper bazaar what i eat in a day and
this time we're after
lost and vampire diaries superstar ian
sommerhalder now with over 40 harper
bazaar
food diaries videos this one has racked
up some of the biggest views
not likely because he's the biggest star
on their roster
but probably because his diet is uh
well let's talk about it first of all
let's talk about my sponsor
now if you're not familiar with
squarespace it's an all-in-one platform
to run your business
whether you're looking to build a
website blog online store
or use their marketing tools and
analytics as a busy dietitian and
blogger myself
i love that squarespace has features
that allow you to schedule appointments
through their online calendar
and set up email campaigns for a mailing
list it's also
easy to seamlessly pull content directly
from instagram or twitter
when everything in your digital presence
works together like this
it makes it so much easier for you to
focus on your actual business
you can check out squarespace.com for a
free trial
and when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com
abbey sharp to save 10 off of your first
purchase of a website or domain
okay now before we get to the meat and
potatoes of this video you can check out
my disclaimer
right here on screen so feel free to
pause the video to read it
or check it out in the description below
also a huge trigger warning here folks
if you've battled or are battling
disordered eating
please consider sitting this one out
and of course don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and ring that bell
so you never miss out on a video okay
so let's get started with his breakfast
so i usually have a broth first thing in
the morning
with a bunch of supplements like vitamin
stuff
and green juices with my
tea that i then whip in the nutribullet
with
coconut oil and cacao and salt
oh i forgot the other thing in the
morning i do
half a lemon lukewarm water and a
quarter of a teaspoon of
pink salt because that just goes into
your adrenals and just
i can't make this up folks but i must
say that this
does feel like every wellness
influencers breakfast that i've ever
reviewed
all rolled into one and yet still
somehow it manages to be really low in
calories
it is impressive to consume so much
with so little actual fuel but anyways
we have a lot of ground to cover here so
ian claims that his smoothie situation
gives him the perfect
combination of electrolytes fat and
caffeine
which gives him a oh of energy as he
says
i don't know of his definition of that's
getting a little
glottal collateral is the same as mine
but i guess i just have to kind of like
take his word for it as true
what i can say is he is getting a lot of
hydration from the broth and tea and
green juice and lemon water
and he's choosing antioxidant and
vitamin rich options as well with the
tea and cacao and the juice
but honestly this meal here
reads kind of like a goop list of
anti-aging
superfoods to start i have talked about
lemon water on this channel ad nauseum
and i've also written an in-depth
article on the stuff as well so i will
link to that below
but to summarize drink it if you like it
as a flavorful way to get your water in
but no it is not going to detox you
de-blow to you cure your acne or lead to
weight loss unless you are
literally drinking it in place of food
the best thing that will come out of
drinking lemon water
is hydration and potentially kidney
stone prevention but
unless ian is prone to stones it's
probably
not a major perk for him as for ian's
comment about it going into your
adrenals
i guess this is in reference to the
wellness culture assumption that
lemon water while acidic is thought by
many to be
alkalinizing due to the fact that it
releases alkaline
byproducts when it's metabolized but
that has no
effect on your adrenals really because
food ph
doesn't even influence blood ph period
blood ph is very tightly regulated in
the body
otherwise we would die quite easily from
eating something
just slightly sour but also if anything
were to help our adrenals function more
optimally it would be
basic stress relief so if a warm cup of
lemon water calms your nerves
then great you have a natural adrenal
fatigue
cure though side note a systematic
review
did suggest that adrenal fatigue isn't
necessarily a real thing
adrenal insufficiency however is
recognized in the medical community
and one outcome of this aldosterone
deficiency is sometimes treated with
extra salt so maybe just maybe if ian is
managing an actual clinical condition
called aldosterone deficiency that his
lemon and salt water
may come in handy but otherwise it's
just a flavorful source of hydration
that was a lot now for bone broth i
mentioned this in my kylie jenner video
right here
but it is a rich source of collagen
protein and gelatin
and has very few calories about 50
calories per cup
it's not going to magically heal your
gut like so many proponents insist
but there is some evidence for gelatin's
role in rheumatoid arthritis
and because it is so high in protein it
will definitely help to fill you up
as for the coconut oil can we just put
that one to bed
coconut oil became really popular
because of its alleged fat burning
properties thanks to its mct or medium
chain triglyceride content
however while mcts are processed
differently than other fats in the body
and therefore they may have slight
metabolic advantages over other
saturated fats
unfortunately most coconut oil only
contains around
50 mcts and the mct
that it's most rich in lauric acid
doesn't appear to have as many of those
ketogenic fat burning benefits
compared to caprylic or capric acid
both of which together only make up
around 12 percent
of its fat as we're getting electrolytes
from himalayan sea salt
yes it does have greater amounts of some
beneficial electrolytes when compared to
table salt
so about three times the potassium 100
times the magnesium
and four times the calcium per gram but
the only mineral you'll get in
substantial quantities in salt
is sodium and there's more sodium in
table salt than that expensive stuff
if that is your goal so use whatever
salt that you like
and get your electrolytes like potassium
from a more abundant
and cheaper source like a banana tomato
or an orange
okay moving on
next ian says that he works out and then
he has another breakfast meal
this time thankfully with actual food
[Applause]
so he says he has two giant handfuls of
nuts
plus some kind of ocean fish or fresh
water fish
broiled or pan-fried in a cast iron
skillet or ceramic pan
but not non-stick in his words
nonstick is as toxic as the day is long
we'll come back to that in a hot minute
he then finishes things off with some
sunflower oil salt and lemon
and serves it with two handfuls of
vegetables
finally he finishes his meal with some
homemade chia pudding made with coconut
milk
chia salt and cacao oh boy
this is going to be a doozy
food burst misinformation first food
burst
misinformation let's
tackle the food first because i'm hungry
so this sounds like a really awesome
meal albeit pretty low carb
but it's quite the production
considering he says he does
all of this before the baby wakes at 8
30 a.m
i mean pretty impressive considering
this mom right here is like
eating toast scraps off of my kids plate
just like trying to survive
but anyway it is nutritious stuff so
we've got
loads of fiber from the veggies and the
chia
fats from the fish coconut milk nuts and
oil
and of course the quality protein in the
fish and this is a substantial size meal
which really helps to make up for the
liquid diet that he described earlier on
now trigger warning i am going to talk
calories for a minute but if he was to
eat all of this
we're looking at potentially up to
around 1600 calories
for this meal alone impressive
now first of all he specifies ocean or
freshwater fish
i assume he means over choosing farmed
fish
and that might be an environmentally
friendly choice
and it might not depends on the species
when we compare farmed versus wild
atlantic salmon for example
we see that farmed salmon has three
times the saturated fat
25 percent more omega-3s and twice the
calories
as wild some wild fish contain higher
levels of mercury
due to bioaccumulation but farm fish
tend to contain
higher levels of other contaminants such
as dioxins
and pcbs and also higher amounts of
antibiotics
as for sustainability some of both wild
and farm seafood is considered
unsustainable
and some is considered restorative so it
would really
heavily depend on the unique species how
it was caught
and where it was caught so when you're
in doubt you're trying to look for a
sustainable choice
run your choice through seafoodwatch.org
to see their recommendations it is an
amazing amazing resource so i'm going to
link
that below okay next let's talk about
the sunflower oil that he mentions which
actually comes in four different
varieties each with relative
amounts of different fatty acids i don't
know which one
ian uses but i will say that the high
oleic variety
is higher in monounsaturated fats and
lower in omega-6
polyunsaturated fats that have been
linked to inflammation when consumed in
excess
so if you're going for sunflower oil a
high oleic variety
is definitely considered the best for
your heart
and then there is the nonstick cookware
is toxic statement
okay first of all i love myself a good
cast iron skillet myself and i do
believe
it's superior to non-stick but i still
want to debunk this myth a bit because
ian's statement felt unnecessarily
fear-mongering
i actually wrote a whole blog post about
this that i will link below
but i think this concern comes out of
the traditional use of a compound called
pfoa and nonstick cookware
which was linked to kidney and
testicular cancer in one study
however not only do we have no evidence
suggesting that using
non-stick cookware specifically can lead
to these cancers
nonstick cookware has been pfoa since
around 2013.
so that one is not really a concern
anymore
unless you haven't replaced your pan now
the teflon coating found on non-stick
cookware today
is typically harmless until it reaches
very high temperatures
so at extremely high temperatures of
around 500 degrees fahrenheit
teflon will begin to break down causing
the release of
two toxic chemicals tetrafluoromethane
and carbon and inhaling these fumes may
potentially result in what is
affectionately known as
the teflon flu in early animal studies
exposure has led to symptoms like
headaches chills
backaches and a fever beginning about
four to 10 hours after
exposure and then resolving again around
12 to 48 hours after exposure
these risks were only evident when the
teflon cookware was heated to
temperatures
over 570 degrees fahrenheit so it's
important to note
that we don't have any human research as
of yet
to determine the relative human risk
also
those crazy high temperatures are rarely
reached when we cook
since most fats and butters and oils
start to smoke around 400 degrees
fahrenheit in more severe cases where
the cookware was heated beyond 660
degrees fahrenheit for an extended
period of time
research suggests the teflon cookware
may increase the risk of respiratory
problems including shortness of breath
and acute pulmonary edema so
should you can your non-stick not if
it's being purchased after 2013
you can simply use your non-stick for
low or medium heat
avoid heating an empty pan so that is
use a little bit of oil or butter to
protect that pan
make sure that you have ventilation in
your kitchen while cooking
and again replace any really old
nonstick cookware from before 2013
that has pfoa ultimately i say new pots
and pans are always a great holiday gift
for the food lover in your life so
maybe you put that on your list for
santa okay so moving on
ian mentions that twice a week he has a
massive
stack of pancakes which really doesn't
surprise me given how restrictive and
low-carb his usual morning routine is
eating his diet i would probably also go
overboard on the carbs when i had a
chance to
but anyways he says that all of that
happens before the baby gets up
around 8 30 a.m and then
we're not done folks he gets to sit and
what does he have
more steamed vegetables because i'm sure
that
is what i would be craving to if i had
only eaten tea and broth and vegetables
and fish before
9 a.m but when it's time to feed the
baby we finally get to see
some variety in play so he describes
having fruit
sheep's milk or coconut yogurt and hash
browns and i assume
not the iconic mcdonald's variety and
side note
like this video if you think the hash
browns are the best thing on the
mcdonald's menu
because i definitely do okay this
definitely seems like a good breakfast
on its own
we've got fiber from the fruit and the
potato hash browns
and some fat and protein from the yogurt
i will say that coconut yogurt
while vegan is really low in protein
like we're talking
1 gram versus 10 grams for sheep's milk
yogurt so
if he does eat animal products the
sheep's milk yogurt might be a better
pick
also i assume he specified sheep's milk
yogurt because of its alleged digestive
benefits
so i definitely want to unpack that
while research specifically comparing
fresh sheet milk to cow's milk is
lacking
there is some evidence on the size of
fat globules and digestion of goat's
milk formulas for babies
now from this we know that the fat
globules of goat's milk
are smaller than that of cow's milk and
some scientists have speculated that
these smaller fat globules
might make it easier for our bodies to
break down but considering that breast
milk globules are even bigger than cow's
milk
it doesn't really seem to make for a
very good case that this would play a
major role
in digestibility difference as for
lactose
cow's milk contains around 4.93 lactose
sheep's milk is 4.76 and goats is 4.33
so if lactose is an issue for you you're
better off choosing
goat's milk dairy than sheep sheep's
milk dairy
is also a premium ticket item since the
average sheep produces
only a half a gallon of milk per day
compared to cows producing
around six to eight so if you like and
can access
sheep's milk products great amazing
they are obviously super nutritious and
for some
they might make a measurable difference
in digestibility
but for most people they're not
necessarily going to
make or break your ability to enjoy some
dairy in your day
let's see what he has to say about his
meal
but when you eat really clean you're
eating
tremendous amounts most of the stuff we
get is
farmers market stuff or we grow it this
is
feeling a lot like that sorella moore
video that i reviewed right here
and that he definitely has a strong
elitist food snob vibe
going on yeah so let's first discuss
ian's suggestion that he grows most of
his food or buys from the farmers market
sure the idea of growing our own food is
so romantic
and probably a really beautiful healthy
way to live
no question about that but it's not
realistic for
99.9999999 percent of people who are
watching
who don't have the time or money or land
or other resources
to harvest their own kale and raise
their own sheep to make
milk and then ferment into yogurt as for
ian's comment that
when you eat clean you end up eating a
tremendous amount
yes nutrient-dense whole foods are
typically lower in calories than
processed foods so
for example calorie for calorie if you
were to have a meal for mcdonald's
with a big mac and medium fries and a
medium drink
you're looking at around 1100 calories
to eat that quantity in the kind of
foods that ian enjoys
you'd be looking at a meal of four cups
of kale
eight ounces of salmon two and a half
cups of potatoes
a cup of sheep's milk yogurt and one and
a half cups of
berries for most people that would be
a pretty large and very satiating meal
much more so than the burger fries and
coke and that's kind of a good thing for
most people
but if ian was finding it hard to meet
his needs eating whole foods
he could add more higher calorie higher
fat foods
like cooking with more oil adding some
avocados nuts
nut butters and seeds okay so we are
done
with breakfast let's talk about lunch
basically it's a lot of the same same
deal
ian says he has more fish huge amounts
of vegetables
he has sweet potatoes quinoa regular
potatoes and
high density fats i'm not totally sure
what he means by high density
i assume he's not talking about hdl
which is high density lipoprotein
aka they good cholesterol in our blood
which
is not something that you can like just
pour on a salad
but if he means calorically dense well
all oils and fats are pretty calorie
dense with somewhere around 100 calories
per tablespoon
so i'd say choose an oil or fat that
works for the job
and that you enjoy and use it in
moderation
next of course is more lemon water which
we already covered
and that's followed by his other
favorite drink or coffee
i do do a lot of coffee and tea but i
also mix it with a tablespoon of coconut
oil
and if you whip it you're binding
caffeine
molecules to a fat lipid so your body
burns it
slower and more evenly as opposed to
like straight up and straight down
uh so okay ian has more coffee in the
afternoon apparently this is his vice
but he says that if you whip it with
coconut oil
you'll get a slower absorption compared
to a massive caffeine rush
so this was an interesting statement and
it's not untrue
though i think he is making it a lot
more complicated than needs be
basically we do have research to suggest
that having caffeine on an empty stomach
will increase blood saturation rate
whereas consuming caffeine
like anything with fat will slow stomach
emptying reducing the spike in caffeine
hit and likely contributing to a more
even but potentially longer buzz
and while whipping or emulsifying is
used for other drugs to modulate
absorption in half light
you'll likely see the same benefits just
from drinking coffee
with some food particularly something
that is rich in fiber
protein or fat it's pretty simple
but anyways let's move on yes sugar is
the devil
one-fifth of all the sugar and one-fifth
of all the oxygen your body intakes your
brain uses
so you have to remember to give it that
i always deal with the rock says
it's not a cheap it's a treat meal okay
so before i talk about ian's
treat meal let's unpack this statement
first of all i'm not sure about the stat
that ian cites suggesting that our brain
uses one-fifth of the sugar
and one-fifth of the oxygen in our body
but i can say
that even though the brain and body can
absolutely function without carbs
that is literally the premise of keto
the brain does enjoy
a good carb so i do agree with him there
where i don't agree
is calling sugar the devil obviously
straight up sugar is not the most
nutritious substance on the planet
but we can make foods morally equal even
if they're not
nutritionally equal and sugar is just
another tool in the chef's toolbox
it's something that can be enjoyed in
moderation
and used to make other nutrient dense
foods more exciting
as for ian's treat meal a name that i
actually much prefer to the ubiquitous
cheat meal he says that he has a giant
stack of gluten-free pancakes with fruit
or maple syrup
now first of all of course they got to
be gluten free
but a reminder to the people in the back
that unless you have celiac or a gluten
intolerance
there's no reason to be choosing
gluten-free products
in fact a lot of gluten-free grains are
lower in fiber and less nutritious than
their gluten-fried
counterparts but anyway ian also says
that because maple syrup requires a lot
of energy to produce
he instead suggests using honey or
making a homemade blueberry compote
sustainability is such a complicated
subject with so much to consider
so what you choose to pour in your
pancakes is really such a personal
choice
now i will say that it is also true that
it takes 40 gallons of sap to make
one gallon of syrup but while this may
sound like
a lot well-managed maple trees can be
a really sustainable option these trees
tend to produce sap for
decades and when they do actually die
naturally
they can then be used to fuel
evaporators that boil the syrup
ideally though of course to keep the
carbon footprint to a minimum
it's best to choose maple syrup from a
local source wherever possible
and thankfully being canadian that's an
easy choice
for me now what other treats does ian
allow himself on his
treat day well it wouldn't be a
superfood listicle without a mention of
dark chocolate which he says he chooses
both for the antioxidants
and the caffeine again i don't know
this guy must just not sleep now for
dinner
ian says he focuses on super crazy
healthy starches
potatoes sweet potatoes quinoa
gluten-free pasta
and then serves that with vegetables and
fish
yawn i mean
this guy's diet is certainly nutritious
but it is
boring as f i am not sure i could eat
that volume of food
every day if i was limited to such a
narrow boring set of foods
over and over and over he does however
describe occasionally making a vegan
meal so
i'm excited about that let's see how he
switches things up you know you can take
one big head of lettuce cut it up put it
in a cast iron pan
water and salt cook it down a bit boom
olive oil
spices whatever you want and bam you
have this like amazing
vegan amazing meal you can put it over
rice quinoa okay um
can we just get something straight
lettuce
like cooked or raw is not a good vegan
meal it's like when you go to a wedding
and check off the vegan entree option
and you are literally just given a plate
of whatever side vegetables
everyone else is getting with their meat
i mean
at least things like carrots and
potatoes would yield some trace protein
and fiber but
lettuce not so much i'm freaking
hungry i mean serve that lettuce with
some tofu or chickpeas or lentils or
something else but all right so let's
wrap this up because somehow i probably
turned a five minute video into like a
20 minute
review but obviously i like a vampire
just as much as any millennial girl
let's be real
but even vampires eat more exciting
diets than this
obviously this is not a dig at ian's
professional life
or his health status or really anything
else about him
he obviously takes really good care of
his body
and he eats an incredibly healthy
nutrient-dense
diet i just feel that this video alone
perpetuates
a lot of food fear and is a perfect
demonstration
of a pretty elitist privileged
relationship with food
obviously celebrities have access to
money
time and other resources that most of us
just do not have
so we can't expect to do everything like
them
but man this diet is just so
far from relatable you would almost
think it was a parody
there are so many competing values a lot
of us have to balance
when it comes to what to eat whether
that's price availability sustainability
ethics allergies family preferences and
more
there should be no shame or guilt if
your choices
are less than ideal for one or more of
these considerations
but friends this is where variety comes
into play
if you are eating a variety of foods not
only are you ensuring your body is
getting
a wide range of nutrients without really
tracking or thinking about it
but you're also diluting the
environmental impact
on any one natural resource so if i were
to give
ian any feedback on his diet not even
touching on his relationship with food
because that would take
a lot to unpack i would say that variety
is the spice of life
and there is a lot more out there than
kale lemon water coconut oil and fish
and on that note thank you again to
squarespace for sponsoring this video
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see me do more of these harper bazaar
reviews
be sure to like this video and leave me
a comment below on who i should check
out next
until then don't forget to subscribe to
the channel ring that little bell so you
never miss out
and i will see you next time on abby's
kitchen bye
you